these photos things are what about
taking maps that you've used and work
like explicitly and then putting them in
a context right
so that's why I quite consciously didn't
say okay well I'm not going to teach you
this is an idea you've met this idea
before for example or that's a good
question eleven this is about percentage
increase I hope do you see in PR
professional talking about these percent
this percent that and it's also about
darlin statistics and interpreting your
graph okay so these are skills you've
used before but never quite in this
exact arrangement so you want to be able
to explain from this context how to use
these skills just have a look at a
particular question for you it says
using the graph of household electricity
prices in Australia compared to other
major economies so here thus here all
the other economies and a particular
question on to focus on is this will
clearly complete the following
statements for reasons that orbital
period freedom we're just going to get
to the second one the price in Australia
is what percent higher than in the EU
countries okay that's what it's asking
so here's Tralee up firstly Australia's
graph is unique it certainly got it's
got two pieces unlike the rest one of
those two pieces in the sharing graph
about yeah so this is like historical
information this is what we've already
recorded and this is how much they
expect based on things by population
growth or what was the climate like this
you those kinds of things okay so when
it says the price in Australia and I'll
give the orange or the blue are you
going to compare orange / red tea are
two other orange / words I don't have
any other moves to compare two
denominators is that the first thing so
I know it sounds little but this is
about how you read graph and how you
look at the equations we presented to
you and you're not going to get the same
rap every single time graphs are going
to be designed differently depending
what are their purposes again so we're
looking there we're comparing to the EU
countries which is the third bar along
okay so firstly I'm going to write down
using Australia's what is the voting
Marcus have a look and sir kilowatt hour
okay so what kind of mineral
cents per kilowatt-hour what does that
mean when you see our graph is higher
than other people's what does that mean
about our country because with anywhere
we'll turn now using one there for
cosmetics
this is household electricity prices
right now I will not get into the
economics of this because we're in a
very big head wound but what this is is
how much we are charging household
it doesn't mean how much it actually
costs you produce it's how much people
in actual you know families and people
living are actually paid right for all
we know electricity could actually cost
the same value all these countries to
produce if that were the case if
electricity cost the same amount
everywhere what might account for one
child one country being higher that is
not think about it do you remember way
back we're talking about peak and
off-peak movement of normal Joe when
you're talking to peak and off-peak
electricity
remember that why do they say at
sometimes is a electricity is more
expensive and other times it's not -
number was originally moment what it
will use it once but so what lots of
people use the road at the same time and
we don't say are you pay different tax
rates depending on what time of the road
you'd run on why do we charge different
we can overpower so the big idea was to
avoid overpowering the traffic system or
the electricity system what we do is we
discourage behaviour by charging it more
that could be ones to them this is what
a pleasure is what in Australia is how
do you really let me help you out a
little bit
24 what are you writing oh I think it's
reasonable to read it I think there's 25
because we're we're 26 B no honey six
would be halfway we're clearly not there
so I think you know we're not expecting
looking at the units for you to get like
decimal points with you like that so
let's say 25
yeah we're comparing us to the EU that's
they aren't and that's easy to read so
now I've got the numbers come back to
the question and make sure you know what
it's asking if they're the price in
Australia is what percent higher than
the EU country just think about that
really carefully the price in Australia
is higher than the EU countries yeah I
know you're like what obviously it is
right I have you just look at the
numbers but I'm going to change the
phrasing the question I'm looking right
down to the semi-trailer but I want you
to listen to this carefully because it's
the same question but will have a
different answer
suppose if I said instead of the
priciest rally is some percent higher
but in the EU countries suppose I
rephrase the question concern the price
in the EU is some percent lower than in
Australia let me save it again same
numbers straight the price in the EU is
some percent lower than in Australia now
it's dealing with the same reality but
the answers to those two questions are
different so my questions are number one
where are those is number two how do you
know which ones are supposed to do let
me show you the air family you can tell
me how I'm doing this first I didn't
know the difference right because it's
about one higher than the other what is
the difference - if five cents unless
you know an hour thank you that's the
difference now what will I do with this
number because I don't want the
difference in kilowatt hours or cents
per kilowatt hour rather all of the
differences of percentage so I did you
compare this with one of these numbers
which one are we only action factor in
the rainy weather in the actual versus
what
this is why we're onto the credit
dispensable I'm glad already the price
Israeli is some percent higher than so
you are comparing on the EU right like
the ease your baseline imagine you're in
the EU and then you move to Australia
right so the is where you started
yeah so what is five cents as a
percentage of the EU underneath answer
is 25 cent okay it's a quarter of 27 now
I gave you an alternative question I
said the prime in they use obviously
lower than in Australia
okay well that way I'm thinking outside
from Australia and transferring over
that's how big the comparison there so
then I would take five percent as a
percentage or 25 that question would
have the answer 20 percent so it's a
little bit like it's actually quite
parallel to the question okay if my arm
if I saw calm and it cost $50,000 right
and then who is discounted to say thirty
five thousand dollars
what percentage off get it what is the
percentage of the discount okay we need
to know two pieces of information
number one Victor the discount what is
the discount from what the other so the
actual Obama table we have Donovan
system $2,000 right so the discount is
fifteen thousand right so I to compare
this to the original price right so if I
compare it to here that's 30 percent
should easily have it if I say it 30%
off right you can't really say to trade
based on your real number not on this
optimum number and that's exactly what's
happening here right so the umbria
number is the EU and then you go higher
than that to Australia does that make
sense so that's why this question is 25
percent not 20 percent you have to read
the questions super different
and this kind of thing it happens it
literally happens all the time